ouais
grosse
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission minutes forme ce nicolas votre
coach sportif aujourd'hui nous sommes en
compagne de johnatan bonjour de n'a pas
besoin du tonnerre je resterai très bien
je te remercie pour le mouvement
classique j'espère que vous également
vous êtes prêts derrière vos écrans pour
voir le mouvement prend l'appel le site
up qui va cibler la sangle abdominale
vous allez venir vous installer sur les
fesses dans un premier temps fléchir les
jambes et placé les plantes de pieds
l'une contre l'autre vous allez à
allonger le dot sur le sol et tendre les
bras derrière l'ouverture de nous va
vous permettre de désengager des muscle
psoas iliaque en contactant les notes
domino d'aller monter et venir toucher
au niveau des pieds
et vous expirez pour venir contracté la
sangle abdominale
natale à toi
installe-toi langue de pied l'une contre
l'autre ok l'objectif vraiment d'ouvrir
vraiment c'est nous pour ne pas engager
les muscles des hanches allonge toi et
tes bras d'aller placer les bras
vraiment eu la tête effectué une grosse
contracture musculaire pour pouvoir
basculer en avant c'est parti
très bien
pour la plupart des exercices
d'abdominaux je vous conseille vous
préconise d'effectuer des séries assez
longue pour avoir une bonne tension une
bonne fatigue musculaire pour avoir des
résultats beaucoup plus rapide comment
ça va dans la donne
ça commence à brûler les bons fait de
plus s'il te plaît allez respire
ok super tu peux t'arrêter comment tu te
sens très bien
j'espère vous allez sentir la même chose
que le la times chérie je vais vous
montrer maintenant l'étirement
correspondance cet exercice alors vous
allez venir vous installer sur le banc
placé les coudes
juste à l'extérieur des épaules joignez
les phalanges d'aller lever au maximum
la pour être une cambrai le dos et tirer
les coup de vernis pour avoir un maximum
d'allongement au niveau des grands
droits
ont respiré vous maintenez la position
entre 20 et 30 secondes à les matins
vous venez vous installer sur le ventre
comme elle le fait joignez les points
les coudes en arrière ou lever la
poitrine et nous reculer au maximum les
épaules tu vas sentir vraiment niveau du
ventre que s'attire oms à respirer
profondément
mais tu relâches très bientôt natale on
peut se vendre et c'est super
matt a bien bossé je te remercie en tout
cas j'espère que c'est pas trop fait
souffrir
bon super geste noble allez sentir cet
exercice chez vous pour faire ses
étirements également après avoir
effectué vos séries d'abdominaux nous
donne un rendez vous pour un prochain
épisode de minutes fort merci nous avons
subi un très bientôt si teps
entraînez-vous trois à quatre fois par
semaine en effectuant trois à six séries
de 20 à 50 répétition éviter la pression
sur la tête et fixer les hanches au sol
non
au titre